اهلا من جديد داليا فرهود شابه عراقيه
بلوجر او صانعه محتوى مختص بالموضه
والازياء عايشه في ليبيا وضجه المنصات
باسمها الايام الماضيه السبب بدايه كان
انباء عن اختفائها واللي جات بعد ايام بس
من اخبار مقتل
العراقيه طيبه علي على يد والدها في جريمه
الشرف لكن بعدين اتضحت الصوره اكثر لمن
اعلن انه داليا اختطفت من قبل جهه مسلحه
مجهوله من منزلها في مدينه جنزوري يوم
الثلاثاء وبين الروايات المتداوله روايه
قالت ان الخط فلو علاقه بخلاف بينها وبين
الاعلاميه الليبيه غاليه ابو زعكوك مشتعل
كان على المنصات والروايه الثانيه قالت ان
الموضوع له علاقه بمحتوى داليه اللي وصفوه
بانه لا يتناسب مع المجتمع الليبي والد
الداليه طلعت للاعلام ونفت علاقه
الاعلاميه الليبيه باختصاب بنتها وقالت
انه الجهه مسلحه تابعه للجهاز الرضع
التابع لوزاره الداخليه هم اللي خطفوا
بنتها من بعد مداهم